oder glaubst dass du es vorher war kurz
vorher war und jetzt im Markt und die
Potenziale von Anif
und
zufrieden
naja ich schon
Playa del Ingles daraufhin hatten denn
sie haben ja vorher gesagt er werde sie
aber Wünsche geäußert Juli aber nicht
aber gleich gesagt Juli eröffneten der
Ochse
Cocker Band Sängerinnen und das sehr
Jung
«Das sagt er jetzt jetzt ist wieder
alles anders und Sieber die euch
gewünscht aber aus Nordholz nun ja
leider setzt
mit müssen erstmal überlegen mit dem
Namen weiter aufteilen hatten ja vorher
lag und wie fix ist wahrscheinlich legal
Nieten und
Heidelberg
bei ein Walliser sind auf jeden Fall
drei gute Stimmen der Bayern es kann
durch gut werden
und jetzt ist kein Tropfen
mal puren Spinning Erfüllung gegangen
drei Jahren Georg Klein und Capella ab
Aabar einen Stecker SZ auf jeden Fall
gut
ich glaube dieses Jahr wird dann
verschwand
hat sich entschieden für Stürmer dazu
wurden
und von daher er hoffe ich mal dass auch
die Leute die Anrufer machen die lesen
sie die Platten kaufen
das heißt es ging zu müssen raus
Abel hätte gern noch ein Wunsch in
Erfüllung oder
auf jeden Fall aber ich kann euch jetzt
nicht verlieren Gewinne dass du denn
gern als Verbinder Band
öl also ich hätte gerne
nach die Kathrin am alten Garten Barbara
derweil einig jetzt Dr ja
also Katrin der und Eper
Wunschkandidatin
aber was ist dann wenn es heute wieder
so läuft Weg ist dann Abend Prozent
gerade die Bar wie eine Super waren
er trifft nicht so ganz die Töne
ja richtig um
alle Mädels in kurzer Sinn ich hier wir
haben alle Ministerien von stand-by gar
Nähe zu uns kommen
im von mit offenen Armen ja
und sein
a aber ist es nicht so grade wenn man so
denkt hier Katrin könnte sein dass die
dann unserem besprüht besonderen Erfolg
so genau steht und dann Maier gestern
Abend so
um dann wollen keinen Druck aus dem
Lager sowas auf gar keinen Fall dürfe
schon
um das Ziel ich will mehr geht als
Sozialarbeiter nicht wohl
so wie ich sie kenne und sie will es
unbedingt es sei sehr spannend sie wird
sich sehr bemühen unten sie wird es
auch möglich machen
gut also wie versteht solche verletzt
weil es ist alles anders gekommen als er
gedacht hat die Methode ist Aufgabe
besonders gute Voraussetzung
um ich denke wir sind drei verschiedene
Typen
und umbringen näher bestimmte Vielfalt
in diese Welt
und also ich bin wirklich soweit
zufrieden
bis die so wie es jetzt ist Kleidung da
wo du bist OK Atommüll an Heide aber
keine andere Wahl gelassen Friedberg
Hanau leider war auch glücklich wird ja
sagen wenn ich jetzt eben jene
weil die kann ich gar nicht über das
alles ist nicht so dass hier ein
einvernehmliches Foster oder gar nicht
abkönnen
ich habe meine gerne Stelle sich jetzt
über ein halbes Jahr zusammen und
Prozent
dapd egal wer es ist jeder von uns denkt
keiner mehr reinfallen ihren härtesten
wissen
und dieses jetzt Prozent gibt es dann
noch zu einer Showband an sowohl die
eigene Favoriten rausfliegt großes
Prozent Weinen
weil er
ich war schon
sehr traurig
das Kinderhaus nun müssen
jetzt nicht erwartet ganz ehrlich
aber es war ja auch wirklich so
letztlich Prozent wenn man das
professionell sieht nicht die Leistung
gebracht
naja Rother
ich bin auch der Meinung dass TAM neben
dem Gesang auch noch andere Sachen und
Fatah haben muss dass
die mehr der Ehrgeiz
der Service das ist aussehen
das kleine
und ich will dass Katar das
Zusammenspiel was hat sie komplett
gehabt
aber es war
leider ein Tick mehr nehmen
da kann man nur im Studio ausbügeln ich
bleibe auf der Bühne und Live müsste
wegen handlich ksta
um
hat er vielleicht noch an die Bar eine
trösten Botschaft
die war
nicht gewürdigt darunter ist ein Martha
nicht mein Ding schon bleiben
und ich glaub wir sehen uns ganz schnell
die haben dann auf jeden Fall in Kontakt
und
du willst dann mach den Fall bei uns
nicht vergessen
vielen dank die auf vielen dank durch
deutsche Treue und dann schauen wir mal
wie es so weitergeht Wetten